president trump says he'll visit the
hurricane victims this weekend today he
campaigns in new hampshire
after repeatedly attacking his
democratic opponent opponent
in last night's speech to the republican
national convention
he used the white house south lawn as a
campaign-style venue full of supporters
the president called joe biden's record
a shameful roll call
of betrayals and blunders and said no
one will be safe if biden is elected
the speech ended with fireworks while
some of his opponents protested outside
paula reed's at the white house paula
was the coronavirus an issue there last
night
good morning anthony looking at this
crowd you wouldn't know that we're in
the middle of a pandemic that still
takes the lives of nearly a thousand
americans each
day now the white house says that anyone
who came in close proximity to the
president
was tested for covid but wouldn't say
what precautions were taken to protect
those in the largely
maskless crowd now throughout this made
for tv
spectacle the coronavirus has really
only been referenced in the past
tense even as the deaths continue to
mount
from fireworks on the national mall to
an entrance
down the stairs of the white house mr
trump used
the people's house as a political prop
like no other president has before
the fact is i'm here
[Applause]
what's the name of that building
but i'll say it differently the fact is
we're here
and they're not the white house is mixed
messaging on the pandemic was also
on full display while americans have
been told to socially distance and wear
masks to stop the spread of covid19
we are focusing on the science the facts
and the data
an audience of nearly 2 000 mostly
maskless people gathered
and while the president acknowledged the
lives lost to covid19
as one nation we mourn we grieve
and we hold in our hearts forever the
memories of all of those lives
that have been so tragically taken so
unnecessary
he continued to pick numbers that
support his handling of the pandemic
the united states has among the lowest
case fatality rates
of any major country anywhere in the
world
but the u.s has one of the highest
fatality rates in the world based on
population
democratic vice presidential candidate
kamala harris
who gave the official pre-buddle to the
president's speech earlier in the day
painted a different picture the tragedy
in all of this
is it didn't have to be this bad
just look around it's not like this in
the rest of the world
all we needed guys
all we needed was a competent president
in his roughly 70 minute address the
president returned to the topic of law
and order a focus of the week
he did not mention jacob blake the black
man who was shot
seven times in the back by a police
officer in kenosha wisconsin
even as racial justice protests have
swept across the country
instead the president attacked what he
saw as mob
rule taking over cities and blamed
democrats for the unrest
your vote will decide whether we protect
law-abiding americans
or whether we give free rein to violent
anarchists
and agitators and criminals who threaten
our citizens biden said earlier in the
day that it was president trump who is
encouraging
more violence he just kept pouring
gasoline on the fire
this happens to be donald trump's
america
the biden harris campaign has also
weighed in on the last night of the
republican national convention
they called it a delusion completely
divorced from the crushing reality
that most americans face gail all right
paula thank you very much